[تصفيق]
اخلافه شويه
هنا
واحده من البؤر الاستيطانيه وليست اخره
حيث تعرض سكانها الفلسطينيون عشرات المرات
للترحيل القسري وهدم منازلهم في اطار خدعه
اسرائيليه تسعى لمصادره اكبر مساحات ممكنه
من الاراضي بدعوى انها كانت مناطق خاليه
ويشبهها الفلسطينيون بالزواج العرفي
ان كان يهودي
مسافر يطخ تجمع سكاني فلسطيني بالضفه
الغربيه يضم 12 قريه يقع في مدينه يطا بين
14 و24 كيلو متر جنوب شرقي محافظه الخليل
ويعد ثاني اكبر مدنها سكانا ومساحه والتي
تقدر بخمسه وثلاثين الف كيلو متر مربع
صنفت اسرائيل 30 كيلومترا المربعا منها مع
خربه ام فجار مناطق اطلاق نار لغايه
التدريب العسكري بالاضافه الى 13 تجمعا
سكانيا اخر يوم 3000 نسمه
ما البؤر الاستيطانيه متى وكيف ظهرت
البؤر الاستيطانيه مواقع استيطانيه صغيره
هدفها تقطيع اوصال المناطق الفلسطينيه
وتعزيز سياسه الفصل الاسرائيلي وتكون
خطورتها في انها قابله للاتساع على حساب
الاراضي الفلسطينيه بدا ظهور البؤر
الاستيطانيه في ستينيات القرن الماضي بعد
حربي يونيو
1967 في حاله اشبه بمسرحيه وزعت ادوارها
جيدا على ابطالها وفيها يتدفق المستعمرون
الجدد القادمون من اوروبا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الى مناطق في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله ويقيمون تجمعا سكانيا ثم
يضغطون على الحكومه حتى توافق على تحويلها
الى مستوطنه فتتهرب بذلك من مسؤوليتها
القانونيه ومن الضغوط الدوليه الحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه ادعت انها لم تمنح
الاستيطان اي غطاء قانوني ولكنها على ارض
الواقع قدمت غطاء امنيا ولوج
لوجودها واستمرارها الامر الذي ادى الى
ارتفاع كبير في عدد البؤر حتى بلغ عددها
في مطلع العام الجاري
186 بورا اقيمت 10 منها خلال عام 2022
ساعد الجيش الاسرائيلي المستوطنين على
الانتقال والاستقرار فيها ووفر لهم
الحمايه وامدهم بالبنيه التحتيه الاساسيه
لضمان بقائهم فيها
82 سنه وش سبعه اشهر وانا ساكن في هذه
المنطقه
وهذاك ولدت في جبل هذا
طوال البلاد اللي احنا خلقنا فيها ما
بننساها من مره ما بننساها لاهله ولا
يهدف الاحتلال من خلال البؤر الاستيطانيه
الى تضليل المجتمع الدولي ولعل ابرزها
مابات يعرف اليوم بالاستيطان الرعوي وفيه
يضع الاحتلال بضعه مستوطنين مع قطعان من
الاغنام للسيطره على مساحات واسعه وتهديد
وجود اصحابها الفلسطينيين عليان الهندي
الباحث بهيئه مقاومه الجدار والاستيطان
يرى ان تسميه البؤر الاستيطانيه بالمزارع
خدعه فبمجرد وصول المستوطنين والسكن في
الارض يسيطرون عليها ويواصلون حياتهم
اليوميه كالمعتاد ومن تجربه ما يحدث على
ارض الواقع فان البؤر الاستيطانيه او حتى
تلك التي يطلقون عليها تسميه مزارع تتسع
وتتطور وتصبح مستوطنه المخططات
الاسرائيليه تواصل تعزيز الاستيطان على
نحو فعلي في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وذلك
برصد الميزانيات وتوسيع البؤر
كولا
على ابن شمرون
هل تتوقف محاولات الاحتلال بالتوسع في
الاعمال الاستيطانيه عند هذا الحد